يبدا النيته في نشر انظمه اي واكس للانذار
المبكر والاستطلاع في رومانيا لمراقبه
النشاط العسكريه الروسيه حسب الحلف في
مهمه تستغرق بضعه اسابيع لم يحدد الحلف
وعدد الطائرات اي وقت التي سيتم ارسالها
الى رومانيا لكن من المعروف انه يمتلك
اسطولا من اربعه عشره طائره
وتجري طائرات اي واكس بالفعل دوريات
المنتظمه منذ شربات فبراير عام 2022 فوق
الشرقيه اوروبا ومنطقه بحر البلطيق سيتم
نشر الطائرات في قاعده القوات الجويه
الرومانيه بالقرب من بخارست من الطائرات
المتمرزه في المانيا و سينقل حوالين 180
من الافراد العسكريين الى القاعده لدعم
الطائره
يصل سعر طائره اي واكس الى 70 مليون يورو
وتحتاج طاقه من 17 شخصا لتشغيلها وتحلق
بسرعه 800 كيلو متر في الساعه على ارتفاع
لا يتجاوز 17 كيلو مترا ويبلغ مدى طيرانها
11,000 كيلو متر وزمن تحليقها 10 ساعات
متواصله يمكن زياده فتره عملها عن طريق
اعاده تزويدها بالوقود في الجو طائرات اي
وقت قادره على مسح ومراقبه مناطق تصل الى
310,000 كلم مربع ويمكنها رصد اي اجسام
تطير على ارتفاعات المنخفضه
ومتوسطتان ومرتفعه انظمتها قادره على
التمييز بين الاهداف الصديقه والمعاديه
تعتبر اي واكس نسخه مطوره من طائره بوينغ
7007 يتم تجهيزها بردار بعيد المدى لرصد
الاهداف في البر الجو تقوم بمهام القياده
والسيطره واداره المعارك كما تتولى مهامه
للاتصالات ورصد الاهداف المعديه